down surf that's okay I don't we none of
us are all right speak to your for
yourself yes speak to yourself sorry
I'll talk to myself hey turn around
speak to yourself hey go to that Court
speak to yourself okay yeah so the other
day
[Music]
welcome back to another very special
careful boys we are very careful boys
today we have Xavier today
Xavier fool he told us that a million
times I watched too much X-Men's for
this [__] yup valid and we got Gilbert
yeah but okay no one cares about him no
no it's not about anybody right now it's
about clicks it's about views Eclipse
views clips and Views it could be about
Clips if you like no no we're talking
about your sexual fantasies sexual
fantasies your sexual fantasies
like for the future yeah but just like
we're gonna start with Colleen and we're
gonna let the video go for 20 minutes I
see you leaning over all right so my
first sexual fantasy yeah number one
number one coming in number one cleans
69 favorite sexual fantasies
you have that many I I don't understand
that reference yeah I know yeah it's
just a number oh yeah yeah yeah
um no I think sexual fantasies on more a
little too abstract I don't think they
ever happen and I don't think they ever
pan out the way that they're supposed to
from someone who gets sex she's like I
don't need a fantasize because I get it
yeah
so we have to fantasize because they'll
encounter that we don't get it right so
maybe let's hear from people who
actually have to fantasize about it I
see that's interesting ah dude that's a
cop-out answer listen from from the
person who deflects the most
show us your penis now hold on he's past
the Baton to me and that's okay I'll
take it it's a tough day today okay
apparently Nick's fantasy is getting
pegged on the air yeah show us that
balloon egg in your butt this one right
here wow I say too much already so I'm
gonna take a seat back seat for this one
fantasy I don't have any fantasy I just
tell everybody do you think it's a
little like Elementary Middle High
School kind of mentality of having a
sexual fantasy because once you become
an adult you've been experienced
no because I [__] but I still got
fantasy it depends on like the context
of what we're talking about
um so once again I think that for us
like it has to be fancy because we don't
really get laid Yeah we don't really
[__]
um but like that's so cool that you get
on yeah that's so cool that like you
guys are all in relationships and I'm
not it's like basically like you you
have like season tickets to Disney and
we're just outside the gates like
looking at me like guess I'll go to
Knott's Berry Farms
Disney's a little overrated long lines
see that that's what we're hearing say
that you would say that
as a season ticket holder she's inside
every day and she's like oh the lines
the clam challenge is not even that good
here
it's cold she's like why would you want
it in a bread bowl it [__] leaks
not my bread bowls oh you should have
asked the hornier room
yeah I think I did
well here's mine mine is always like the
idea of like accidentally falling into
sex so like like girl like whoops my
addiction side
oops here's the thing all my fantasies
so they turn into bits with my wife so
now it's like I do this thing where I'm
like always pretending I'm falling into
sex where I'll be like just naked and
I'll head butt her butt like oh man your
butt I just fall over yeah and she
starts laughing it kind of it does it
could it can lead to it but it's the
commitment but mostly your wife just
hates you yeah because I literally just
like I ran from my head go I'm in your
butt naked I mean it's just fully
clothed me after this okay
let me ask you this you're a horny son
of a [__] okay so do you already did
you already perform out all those things
so then it's not a fantasy anymore
because this is what I'm thinking like
I'm drawing blanks because if I did have
them I was able to accomplish them
because I [__] Crush yeah yeah yeah
yeah cause you're Rising grinder you're
right
hashtag hustle completely goes against
what Steve was Steve was talking about
how you guys have fantasies because you
didn't accomplish them yeah that's true
I do have I do have fantasies you know
I'm not really following no that's true
I do what are your fans I told you guys
my mind are super lame what's this
[__] I gotta deal with about JK news
I gotta [__] give you a legal
definition
honestly do it actually do your
Webster's version of defining fantasy a
fantasy is something that you imagine
that hasn't not that easy huh well no
it's something that you're imagining
that I would love to have happen right
bro I couldn't write more novels than
Daniel Steele that's how much [__]
can you write one all right
one novel
all right because I swear to God on my
life I will read it every page yeah I'll
read the ISBN number and memorize it you
might get too horny though and you're
gonna be like damn Joe you're making me
horny bro fantasies
my homie made me Hardy
I think I think
it depends right because you could start
off comedic but you can also start off
like
just like oh uh uh hentai like where
it's like this will never [__] happen
but you know a boy [__] wrote this
[__] yeah like oh
my I've been failing at school and for
some reason you know I just everyone
[__] thinks I'm stupid and I get made
fun of that class and then like
my mom was like I ain't taking this [__]
no more so I'm gonna hire a tutor by the
octopus home
my dad's awesome
just so happened to be a squid
so it's tentacle porn the nope the no
beat kind
yeah those are way better dude those are
way better no but something like that
I've been able to start off like that
was there ever a sexual fantasy you had
that was accomplished and you were like
wow I can't believe I did that having
sex
I'm just happy to be in the room because
I don't know about girls but I I feel
like all guys right like you're in high
school you're a virgin or whatever and
your fantasy is to just have sex yeah
that is like the best thing in the whole
world I'm really glad we're starting at
the bottom of the bear JK fans you're
being lied to at all times they're all
like oh man I love how real and raw you
guys are and then it's like what's the
legal definition of fantasy
and then Nick's like like I don't know
like I don't know
take it Ryan
that's so good it's because Ryan like
what are you doing
it's an unbelievable
let's make it not fun because zoomy was
sitting right there we would all be
divulging our [__] fan exactly but I
don't like looking at you guys talking
about sexual things you want me to pull
up a picture first you can [__] hear
stuff yeah she makes sexual
conversations way more comfortable so
you're saying you're saying that the woo
man can't make it comfortable for you
what do I gotta do man nope we're not
attracted to you like that okay have you
ever fulfilled your sexual fantasy but
then you were disappointed after yes
anal sex agreed I think a lot of people
say that they hurt much more than I
thought I'm just kidding
I would say my uh doing it on the an on
like during the laundry so the washer is
on because I heard about it and then I
just couldn't reach so it was really
embarrassing oh that's bad
dude well you didn't get a stool or
anything like that it's a stackable
I was just like
and then you're like I don't care what
the hype is about I can't even read your
[__] baby I'll be up there in a minute
you crazy fool
oh [__] you can't do that on a double
stack yeah that would be disappointing
yeah are you married
yeah pretty much pretty much pretty much
I love being on each other
since eighth grade songs oh you're like
legally married see so he fulfilled all
his fantasy High School
is that true
yeah I'd say if there was one it'd be
let's put it into terms that we could
really digest this
is
familiar with Indiana Jones yeah yeah
are we familiar was she the stone
chasing you could you explain Indiana
Jones to me I'm not familiar adventurous
treasure I mean she was a Treasurer your
girlfriend looks like Harrison Ford
she's a treasure okay
and you're a treasure hunter I am okay A
little Laura Croft Auntie Kawaii on
Instagram if you guys want to check it
out
yeah I know I was Boston jokes I'll do
but for real does your chick belong in
the museum
I mean
there could be an insole
Fine Art
do you have a fantasy with this chick
that you haven't done yet
you ever shove your dick in her ears
no no no we don't
I don't think people in Hawaii do that
kind of stuff what but I can't speak for
everyone I just haven't okay yeah they
Buck on surfboards though surfboard no I
haven't I can't I don't serve really I'm
the only I know that's it's okay I don't
we none of us are all right speak to
your for yourself yes speak to yourself
sorry I'll talk to myself I have a wave
hey turn around speak to yourself hey go
to the courts speak to yourself okay
yeah so the other day I was wonderful
this is good I have a foam wave surf
board okay so that I bought at Costco
bit I got one too dog nobody is gonna
tell anybody their fantasy here right
okay cool okay I already told you about
my stackable ones I couldn't do it it's
just like you know fantasy wise I feel
like in general and I know you guys are
gonna be like yeah you're [__] lying
I'm practically a virgin right so why
did you look to rock Mormon actually I'm
practically a virgin am I right we
talked yeah they almost had a moment no
no just because I met my lady
in high school so we're a high school
sweetheart so we've been with each other
ever since right so we're practically
virgins okay but as far as like what we
like to do it's like it's we're straight
up just standard we're very vanilla dude
once again I'm just happy to be in the
room when she's having sex with somebody
else you know what I mean I love that I
like that is that my fantasy it could be
no but I'm I'm down I do a lot of things
but I wouldn't know if it's a fantasy
yeah like I'm I have Curiosities like
I'm down like I want group sex but not
with guys
[Laughter]
yeah
but your cheeks never shifted so much
like nobody even said with guys but then
he like he added it yeah no because when
you think about when you think about
group sex you think
there's guys in there too that's what
you're dreading I don't want to see
another man's dick okay what are your
sexual dreads
what are the things you don't want to
happen with all your heavy setups I feel
like we boarded the [__] out of our fans
for the last 10 minutes
I think I think you're you're exactly
right I'm not a do a different video
just cut this one this has been pretty
funny honestly really okay
as I said that's why I'm not gonna go
last because wherever you guys have it's
[__] nothing to what I want they go
for it no because I'm the only one
that's why I said I want to be in a room
full of horny people you guys ain't
horny enough I'm horny but I'm waiting
for what I was born married
what's the point I might as well be
Jordan and [__] score all the points
do you actually have any real fantasies
currently
unfulfilled current right now fantasy no
Steve's not that horny he's the kind of
guy that pulls his dick out of his
zipper to have sex yeah well don't we
all that's okay
but he leaves his clothes off have you
ever been accused of not being horny
yeah yeah you're not horny dude you're
[__] phony yeah accusing that for my
guy I swear I'm horny I swear to God hey
you don't really see in that morning
actually he said he's horny and waiting
I bet I bet you don't have any real
sexual fantasies dude honestly I do uh
so I so I am I got a couple so I am in a
relationship with a woman who is my wife
and but she's also my [__] she's my
submissive [__] and I enjoy that I and
I'm not lying and yeah one of my one of
my things about it is I like to make the
[__] my [__] and I do
um all the time and I really I fantasize
about it and I keep on repeating the
same kind of so she yell I'm your [__]
she says that's your [__] Etc yeah she
calls me daddy that calm though yeah
yeah yeah well no she needs to say it's
mine or else I'm insecure about it right
right right yeah and she needs to say it
over and over again otherwise especially
since you two are the only ones in the
room clearly your vicious cycle
snowballs I get really insecure if she
doesn't keep saying hey you didn't say
it that much in the last time I start to
get emotional because if she hasn't said
it in like three and a half seconds I'm
like what's going on like is there
something wrong did I do something are
you mad at me yeah do you still love me
like you used to yeah yeah that's a good
question to ask it's good that's she
doesn't she says no
but at least we're still having sex
I feel like a weird therapy session why
did you leave Joseph hey dude I I have
sex bro I'm just trying to make it work
I was trying to make this prompt work no
here's a better question though it's
it's kind of going back no like
seriously right is that when you ask
this prompt all of us are pretty much in
our 30s we've been in long-term
relationships or we've had [__] sex
right so that speak for yourself dude so
that thought it's like when I'm in my
20s or whatever and you just it's still
this oh I want to [__] try this and
then it's like what's your fantasy
getting a [__] man it's so basic
right yeah but then when you when you've
had it then is it even considered a
fantasy anymore it's more like just real
life like it's a it's a prerequisite to
the relationship kind of but there's
still guys who are like you know I want
to have a threesome for example I do I
couldn't handle it you really I don't
want that no none of you guys want a
threesome you're just looking good on
[__] camera I swear to God the idea
of having
another man is terrifying
soon
guess what because my wife ain't gonna
be two girls so in my mind it's already
another guy it seems huge [__] that's
not true I think with Steve's question
it it it it excuses us from having to
include reality yeah it's just but
that's what a fantasy is right it's just
like
I'm on a [__] plane and the pilot she
[__] goes on autopilot and sucks my
dick like that's a fantasy right that is
a fantasy yeah I wish somebody said that
oh I'll do that one but that's what I'm
saying is I have it I could [__] these
ideas left and wrong it doesn't make it
feel anything because to me it's I feel
like a fantasy for me has to be like oh
I could do that if I work it right I can
get into that yeah like if it's so is it
too dangerous because you're too you're
too hard I want to have sex with uh
gauzer dog I'm not having sex with gal
gadots I don't care yeah are you sure
though you're pretty close to gal gadol
you're closer than we are in what way
she could be on tigerbelly dude
hey let me um have a producers talk with
you real quick hey George Kimmel could
you hook it up Gal Gadot George camel
he's like oh yeah oh yeah
so I used to work at Laker um didn't get
Equity points no no no no no but it's
worked out for me okay
this is why I don't work with amateurs
oh I have a fantasy having sex tonight
dude that'd be cool if I get some sex
tonight that'd be great sick that'd be
sick that's a cherry on top of the day
that's a that's a better question is
when you're in a long-term committed
relationship
the um you just don't [__] a lot anymore
false you block more
you don't [__] like the same year the
intensity might be the same maybe not as
like the same company
[Laughter]
if you're working 15 hours a day or
whatever you come home both of you guys
are [__] okay so our fantasy is even
worth it
I guess it depends on the fantasy all
right I I think it's it's like it's like
why don't you rate something 10 out of
10. it's because you're reaching for
something so like you know there's some
there's some kind of idea maybe behind
fantasies it's like kind of fun in that
way it's like oh well you're still
trying to reach for that next I don't
get road head while she's driving
that's cool
plus I feel like there's always this
like expectation that's just never met
with that fantasy so there's always a
letdown you think so what's the most
yeah what's the what was your fantasy
let down what was the biggest letdown
yeah were you like I'm not like you Joe
why I'm not like as promiscuous and like
I'm not promiscuous I'm not Joe you
little [__] I just I'm I just have
imagination you know I'm not taking my
dick out of my zipper everything the
idea of Joe being promiscuit is pretty
funny I am not I miss you as good I mean
you know where you are I'm not a jezebel
so you don't get your legs because I'm
up like a baby and you're a butthole
eating out like
and by the way
I know that that's the visual visual bad
I'm bent over I'm bent over I'm turned
around you
do know yeah he was in the room he's
told me many times
but that's the kind of guy I
accomplished my fantasy but I also feel
like I know some fantasies that you
would have I could just assume there's
something that I feel like you know what
you want to truth and false with me yeah
let's go go ahead okay have you done
this or have thought about this yeah you
know those women that uh put sushi on
their bodies naked I feel like you want
to be that woman with a sushi off your
body and then some guy some woman just
like grabbing like a Hamachi and lady
goes
you don't know me at all food in him
and him 14 clementines exact second he
doesn't like food and sex Buddhist sex
is overrated too that's overrated sex is
overrated no food in sex I completely
agree when you combine it it's like what
are we doing see that's a fantasy
expectation that doesn't live to the
hype oh also one of the shower showers
kind of whack yes absolutely shower
jacuzzi you guys are poor you got to be
in a big shower no I don't have a small
shower too I still have to do with the
water we're showering outside I'm by the
hose dude we have plenty of space thank
you it's open air exactly I don't like
shower
something about water it delubes you
yeah yeah it's not a steam room yeah
yeah at the YMCA Rich oh YMCA that's the
YMCA in the bathrooms in the sink
you brought your wife in the YMCA
bathroom what's the small place called
Lanai
oh dude but Lanai has a YMCA with a
steam room and you brought your and you
brought a girl inside there yeah but
it's a YMCA like why young men's
Christians associations is that I'll do
a Christian Association how did you get
her inside you know you just you snuck
her in yeah young man yes I'm talking to
you
where's my wife ago yo
like this